where's it feed in my life she make a
sure my next book should be called like
drinking with Rhonda you know good tight
grip
feel the chest
tight upper back
yeah for the last month good don't
morning so um I grew up a humongous New
York Knicks fan and I actually hate
Michael Jordan with my entire heart is
in another business and then I went into
it being an agency I'm in b2b now one
thing I learned about b2b is it's easier
than b2c it is it's easier because you
fundamentally actually know the name of
the [ __ ] person you're selling to
like it's Rick Thompson from Microsoft
it's not [ __ ] brain science how many
people would be to be here yeah [ __ ]
jackpot so one thing that I'm very
worried about very worried about is that
I believe that this is a roomful of
trans actors that this is a room full of
people in sales not in business building
not in brand building not in marketing
sales people and by the way remember how
I started this talk this is not me
looking down I am a salesperson I'm a
sales person that ran direct mail and
radio and local TV and outdoor
billboards and then Google Adwords
I bought the word wine on Google AdWords
the day Google AdWords started for 5
cents a click and owned it for nine and
a half months before anybody bid me up
because that's what you do when you day
trade attention you buy underpriced
assets while everybody's over pricing it
like today March 9th only because the
book came out yesterday March 9th
sorry Siri March 9th 2016 I know that
for a lot of people in this room that do
digital scalable transactional b2b if
you're running Google AdWords and
affiliate marketing that you don't and
this I mean individually some of you may
but I'm looking at the overall behavior
because they are not practitioners in
facebook marketing they are headline
readers in facebook marketing yeah there
you go [ __ ]
Oh [ __ ] good to see you doing a
front yeah
you awake I'm awake you know once you
get on stage example and takes over
great thank you brother thank you yeah
zero fast dude
I can't keep it up thank you the walnuts
345 years old downloading snapchat and
adding you first how again is that the
best keep it up thank you baby thank you
we get D rockin on the damn picture here
but then I'll see you over nice and man
originated don't worry much awesome say
well thank you thank you for joining
I like the shocking value I've never
heard of you before until today oh well
thank you I love it
thank you brother good luck to you stay
well ask you the picture Hooper do it
our parents were Colombian we know the
whole immigrant very I saw you this
morning at 6 a.m. in Atlanta that's
what's next no [ __ ] that's all I hear
amazing
thanks about
ah
hey Louise
real pleasure my pleasure the Barnes and
Nobles yeah maybe
got a focus on like I got it I've been
following you since daily great huge fan
of your work thank you Ron
emphasize the books that I bought for
other people I just want to get value
any way that I can thank you brother
yeah well go to [ __ ] work you got it
we're on video yeah that's what we're
doing
[ __ ] I mean I wasted three seconds I'm
sorry okay how are you doing Dan how are
you
there was damage Ian got it can you tell
her my snapchat followers you told me
Daniel because it's a big job dude this
is crazy I just called Dane Dan and I
actually gonna I'm just gonna call you
Dan from now on is that right that's the
best thing ever
dan finally hanging out with Gary B
minor Kyle Kyle I finally for me I'm
hanging out with Kyle that's what's up
good to see you Brad the CT thanks Rolly
thanks for all the interacting man yeah
open you Maya
I'm Mitch is no longer believes because
Yanni good Badou yeah yeah yep sharp
sharp pointy Maya is your dad proud yes
of course
like I'm 42 from Russia as well and
where I see dudes birth a penis I am
just sitting same story don't you come
over I get a 95 nice yeah of course all
right
alleged man I hope you enjoy it stay
well brother my man Capri I wish you
well keep us alive anything yes
be patient you're young okay be patient
yeah you got time but after hearing you
today I was like all right that's it
I'll jump on
broke it down you might be my first yeah
hell yeah I don't know what the hell
you're doing good do that yep this is
your first snapchat where's that job
well what do you want to say to
everybody
snap track this is good
I'm Garen B oh my god there's no a lot I
didn't know about this I forgot about
maker you forgot about it ring I forgot
about it
you're crazy oxygen here thank you right
so started watching the show in July yes
since then I'll directly attribute two
million dollars in growth in the
business to just mindset and and tactics
but mainly mindset one more time brother
Josh Helen and hard-hitting I'm kidding
do you rock I don't you guys go Jack
thank you thank you that's that is
exactly what I'm trying to do you're
helping I'm trying brother
I can't realize I'm happy are you
gathering guys yeah I wanna say thank
you brother cuz uh I century know what
I'm asking if I could do a one-on-one
with you I feel myself help yep you
responded yep and that's talking about
us we're not have attention to get very
appreciated by Amanda thank you a
careless mistake a great job take care
okay so you got I need your lead at one
okay that's good so we'll do a quick
lunch let's do it I got some folks won't
ask you something to us it's to it but
you got through everybody yeah that was
a good job I thought I was I thought
that was a really good job by you to
make that happen you know I found out
right there that was the right move my
man uh in opposition to the intro move I
know it's so perfect that made it so
hard you know see except for and and I
said he's gonna he's gonna like I had no
clue
I mean I've watched you speak about
sighs I never heard don't run you know I
talked I don't talk much about it it's
common man what's cool though is there's
nothing better than getting punched and
getting up it tastes up cuz when you get
up neither's like that scene in every
movie we're like every week there's that
scene in cliche movies where the guy
gets punched directly in the mouth but
he just turned spits his blood out looks
the guy back in the face I live for that
in business I live for that yeah I live
for that [ __ ]
is there a key for again I feel like
rocky force like taking over my life
yeah introduces duty what falls off what
does it be done a hundred interesting
everything I'm not crippled by being at
a sixty like ten if I didn't work on my
personal brand Tennessee
would have two more clients cuz I would
help picky Colette like things but then
if I didn't build a brand would we close
something without even doing an RFP like
it all you know things uh all of them
I'm not crippled by anything that is a
vulnerability or shortcoming or a loss
I'm literally basically the 1990
you know Loyola Marymount basketball
team I'm trying to win 172 to 163 got it
I'm such other offense got it what's
good is what people don't get is this is
good for you to hear you do I believe
you do that early like early and then as
you get maturity use money to do what
the Broncos did and build your defense
and I think way too many people play
defense too early in a company you'll
parent a kid that's three and four the
same way that your parent to kid at 16
and 17 and some people try to run
businesses as if their kid is 17 and 18
they're like read [ __ ] Jack Welsh
books or or their dad did a surveying
that they think that's maturity in your
first five to seven years as long as you
don't go out of business if you can grow
top-line revenue that's pretty much what
you should be doing
when you walk by one of your employees
desk and you can feel in your stomach
that they're having a bad day you should
investigate it like I don't know like am
i supply I don't know I know that that's
something intuitively in me that I know
that other people don't have any vehicle
left unattended will be ticketed until
ok areas only
hi guys do it snapping at wrapping it up
big J we should make fun of hey Lazaro
and more and I think very Todd massacre
Todd do it real pleasure yeah thank you
- thanks for coming yeah thanks for
having me
yes yes you're welcome gosh yeah let's
do it
it's the best part
wait wait let's get a shot is that a
video he's doing but he's doing the
daily be fed ready I'm sort of watching
daily B's yet no should I d rock should
he start watching our daily beef comes
out comes out I'll see I'll see you
later
hello thank you hi pretty girl hi Elena
adorable but she okay with that some of
the potty words that might happen okay
hey man good man how's everything really
good you'll be here for two days
yes so obviously you tomorrow I hope so
get it tarnish
take away boys thank you guys
sup where's the fire I'm just from the
fireside chat I'll bring some [ __ ]
fire oh I was told that there are
families and children I'm sorry that was
a poor decision I spent you know five
six seven years now eating [ __ ] I mean
it going from where I was financially
and all the opportunities I had in my
life the idea to they'll go and start a
client service business and go to
meetings with associate brand managers
who go to Babson and tell me how to sell
[ __ ] [ __ ] you you know and so and so you
know I absolutely have deployed enormous
amounts of humility and patience in the
last five or six years which is why when
I meet youngsters or even people in
their 40s and 50s I always push those
attributes yet nobody wants to deploy
them because they're not attractive and
they're not quick ratifications but they
absolute the pillars of success
very nice for me do you know that did
I'm guys need to hug it out I love it
okay I appreciate that
yes I'll repeat this for you guys daily
B people are starting businesses out of
college and haven't even self told
anything in their life and I wasn't
happy before I got injured yes I think I
my idea but maybe I was meant to be a
manager world leader but I don't know
which one I'm supposed to be and that
ties into self awareness it does I was
just wondering what's your opinion maybe
you say entrepreneurial so I'm glad you
asked this question you know I think
when you're as young as so many of you
are I think what you really need to
think about is a more holistic patient
strategy I think in a first five-year
window of like hitting the marketplace I
would actually I think the right
blueprint
I think the much smarter selfish thing
to do because the selfish thing to do is
start a company I had a funny meeting I
don't know if you had one of these yet
I've been telling this story lately I
don't mean the other day with a kid
whose business is going out of business
sober lost couldn't raise his next round
because that's what's gonna happen none
of these people actually built a
business they built a financial
arbitrage machine that was built to make
the next race happen and keep going
until either got bought or something
good would happen so they don't build
businesses these startups on businesses
these startups are machines that were
built to raise more money through users
or other things so we're sitting there
and he's like you know you know yeah man
it's over he's really whatever and I
like have a sad face cuz I'm
compassionate look and he's like and
he's like and he sees it he goes oh Gary
don't know like don't don't worry man
like I learned a lot I'm like I'm not
worried about that dick I'm worried that
you lost 150,000 of my dollars
and what he doesn't know is that what we
do as VCS and angels for years is we
talk about all these people and see how
they're navigating or they're not and
your reputation is much more valuable
and so it's important for self-awareness
and I think the selfish thing to do is
actually go live a 5-year blueprint
where maybe do try to start something
the first year out I think it's a great
thing to do you get to learn something
about yourself maybe you go and get a
job because I think interning for real
like up like a full pledge
I'll give you real real value and and
I'll do it for nothing just but I really
want to be like you if you want to be
like a hip hop mogul business person
like it's really a good idea to like
just when you're 22 it makes a lot of
sense especially if mommy and daddy are
on your side and you can afford it it's
like a really good idea to hit up all 55
hip hop mogul executives in the world
and be like I will work for you for free
for 15 to 18 hours a day because I can
tell you this Phil Toronto Nate Playa de
Mayo my personal assistants become
beasts because they're so close to it
dee rocks getting smarter by the second
true yes dear hi okay questions first
one what is your secret to greatness uh
I would say empathy and the second one
one day hits rock bottom
what brings you back up when you really
hit it gratitude and because I just come
I'm just those empathy allows me to
really care and think about what you're
thinking and that helps me in sales it
helps me be likable it helps me navigate
it helps me make decisions about
products and services it helps me so
much and gratitude because I never
really fully hit rock bottom at like in
a business contact the only thing that
will ever make me hit rock bottom is the
sickness or death of somebody I love
there's nothing else there's no deal I
didn't hit rock bottom when now I
couldn't work together anymore because
they wrongfully
made their only KPI YouTube video views
for 2015 I went out I went out and got
as a client you know like like I I don't
hit rock bottom when you know somebody I
love and admire want to build around has
to leave my company for circumstances
that neither one of us can control I
adjust I make the best out of it in
business I never hit rock bottom because
I business squarely pegged where it
deserves to be which is the health and
well-being of my friends and family the
New York Jets business thank you
awesome where am I going man make sure
you know before through New York see all
right well this man oh great
how'd you enjoy it good thanks great
good to see you yeah thanks so much for
coming big big fan just watch this video
stuff it's crusher man it's been a great
pleasure thank you you could you saw my
book and take a spell so yes you're the
man another said what's up brother Oh
serious girl thanks so much about it
okay well you killed about it's my dad's
birthday tomorrow
yes - very good yes what's amazing is
Vinayak so open the other one he's gonna
stop wonderful finish
vinayak its Gary Vee I'm here with your
son
what up he's good-looking which means
you're good-looking have the best
birthday ever ahead
take care I'm nothing I'm Scott space
New Jersey get the hell out of ya yeah
that's also I love that request data yes
I put me in a headlock yes thank you
thanks for coming tonight
really appreciate it his name's Patrick
Patrick it's Gary Vee uh
Jen's excited yeah what a [ __ ] are you
that's close dick thank you much yeah
what was it
hey did you hear what you said about our
bootstrapping Gary Luke happens the game
man
you never do it even if feelin it even
if the economy was phenomenal whoo
trappings better than raising money you
own more your business like it's it's so
crazy how good venture capital and that
world has convinced people that that's
the route go faster sweet I witnessed
you accept that Marissa thank you for
coming and then I know everything that
makes them tick i reverse engineer
everything they want in life money fame
hanging out work-life balance I figure
out what they care about
that's how you do it quick quick photo
right here
nope blurry one too Oh video you know
what Oh video oh [ __ ]
what's up man from Miami
follow me carry big man oh hey hey
dolphins man
No Oh jack ha ha ha thanks Gary effects
it's like one of these days I may I'm
gonna join the board in my nonprofit
Kevin I believe you but you're gonna
have to crush you're gonna have to be
patient
you're gonna have to be persistent and
you're gonna have to not be soft
that's easy all right good to see ya
that's a lot - good luck - Paul how are
you uh can you draw clouds in a dirt yes
yes look at that tree yes son around my
bad
- Paul business
that was pretty good do the India party
apart yeah are you want me do the whole
thing yeah just be ready enjoy yeah
Sabrina are you ready for it I'm ready
let's get into the show
good job got it take care say well no no
where's noise you like Gary Vee oh [ __ ]
all you guys are into video huh no
follow me Gary Vee hey Sam it's Gary you
are very sweet and I'm the best
Vaynerchuk sibling not my sister ha ha
ha hey Cal Cal all right now's good
all right oh god there we go good good
good
awesome take your car real nice to meet
you and I hope you enjoyed tonight okay
yeah thank you brother thanks bye
darling great to see you thanks for
coming
you're welcome awesome guys thank you so
much again for all your help it really
means a lot to me thank you thank you
yeah you didn't success hope you enjoy
the book thank you my man nice nice to
meet you love that name mich mdec I mean
Vince cage
things to you back to like December I
can watch dog business is kind of killer
could bring you go
often thank you so much ma'am thank you
could you see you again always a
pleasure Gary Thank You Man
I know I know our selfies done so I'm
good but I'm sorry sure I mean it's
gonna be driving it's got dirty dude
you're young yeah although nobody wants
to be patient be patient you've got
nothing but how do you high seven yeah I
mean you've got a mess in this team at
this game he's a little bit ha ha I'm
here you got nothing but time way more
you think you can do nothing nothing
right for four years and you're nine
years younger than so many different
people um I see so much there anything
no oh my friends that's different like
get married kids house okay I'm just
like this
second you start letting outside [ __ ] be
a factor second your loser I don't give
a [ __ ] about anything
try try thank you I wish you well okay
hurry how are you
are we now in your crew is this like
this essentially is this is what happens
now is what happens real pleasure
forget there you got it hi thank you
[ __ ]
Fran how are you good please about I
mean edge - educational technology have
a company that's here yes are tight and
I heard they haven't told me that you is
in fact I did so I'm looking at another
one right now I know I don't have a
question for you I'm just awestruck also
coming on picture let's get in here
what's your name young man
you ready it's good to see right you
ready rock and roll sim
it's good that you're in Boston I'm
excited your flight got delayed today's
uh yesterday that was already yesterday
that's how much [ __ ] [ __ ] has
happened in 24 hours Meech scary be my
man
it's time to put up or shut the [ __ ] up
here we go get out big man get up there
yeah every morning every morning